[Music]
john's with us in louisville kentucky
hey john how are you
hey dave thanks so much taking my fall
sure okay
i'll just get to the point here real
quick um
my son needs braces if we pay the braces
up
front we will save 500
okay out of 4 600 so we'll it'll be able
to pay for 4100
now we have 3 700
in savings we have forty five hundred
dollars
in the bank so we could pay for that
cash now she wants to pay for it to save
the five hundred dollars
i don't wanna i wanna pay the thousand
dollars and then we can make
i think it's 188 dollar payments for 20
months
because my furnace is 17 years old
and my car it has almost 300 000 miles
on it and i drive
27 miles one way every day
and i i just need some rules
okay well um
i've been doing the show 28 years i've
never told anybody borrow money yet
and this is borrowing
if you want me to blow the whistle and
throw the flag i can but um
but yeah but you're right too i mean
you've got some valid concerns there so
how do we
what are some ways we can look at how we
get to these other issues the furnace
and the car
uh because we're taking you dangerously
low on cash and so
if we're gonna do this uh for this child
now and not wait six months which
probably wouldn't be the end of the
world if you did i'm not
an i'm not an expert on dentistry but i
suspect they would
probably still be able to straighten
their teeth if you wait six months
and um which might be a plan and during
that six months pile up some more cash
to
where it gives all of you some more
comfort uh that's
probably what the ramses would have done
but if you don't do that then what we do
have to do is we have to put the house
on the whole home on beans and rice rice
and beans as if you had a bunch of
credit card debt or something
and you're being gazelle intense because
you've got some known
things coming at you so your analysis of
that is correct i mean that furnace is
going to go out and that car's going to
go
there's not any question in your mind or
my mind i just don't know when
it's not a matter of if it's just when
is it six months or is it 18 months
but it's not it's not eight years you
know i never even thought about waiting
i mean it
sounds silly i never thought about
waiting six months he's he's 11 and a
half he's got all this permanent teeth
i've never thought about waiting six
months
i'm sure the doctor is going to tell you
that i'm a quack because when it comes
to dentistry i am i have no
qualifications whatsoever
except i'm a dad that bought a couple of
sets of braces over the years
i did i did do the same exact analysis
and
they don't they make it almost sound
like you're not borrowing money it's
more like you're renting
these braces but they'll give you a
discount for paying the rental up front
like they're gonna re-rent them after
you give them back but anyway i don't
know
but it's uh to me i looked at it with
our two that had braces as
debt and i just pre-paid it like your
wife is suggesting but
i think that means that we have to look
at there's three valid
things that need to occur here furnace
car braces
and we've got to treat all of them like
they're very important
because they are and john i i need
you didn't ask for this but i just got
to speak it out there i know the tension
i feel when i want to buy something when
i have to buy something
and then my wife says hey hank needs
shoes
and the temptation is to let him know
i'm buying you these shoes at a cost up
right
so the temptation is going to take that
boy you better appreciate that
i'm driving this truck because and what
i'm going to ask you to do is don't put
that
in the heart and soul of your 11 year
old that he's a burden to his family
that dad can't drive to work or we can't
have heat and
john doesn't say that and you said i
know he didn't i know he's making sure
he doesn't yeah
if everybody out there man take care of
your kids because that's the right thing
to do and don't
don't make them feel more of a burden
they already do